When you put all this together, you find that all these possibilites on the Gaussian over here,
link to a Gaussian that looks like this.
This is a really interesting 2-dimensional Gaussian, which you should really think about.
Clearly, if I were to project this Gaussian uncertainty into the space of possible locations,
I can't predict a thing. It's impossible to predict where the object is.
The reason is, I don't know the velocity.
Also, clearly if I project this Gaussian into the space of x dot,
it is impossible to say what the velocity is.
A single observation or single prediction is insufficient to make that observation.
However, what we know is our location is correlated to the velocity.
The faster I move, the further on the right is the location.
This Gaussian expresses this.
If I, for example, figure out that my velocity was 2, then I was able, under this Gaussian,
to really nail that my location is 3.
That is really remarkable.
You still haven't figured out where you are, and you haven't figured out how fast you're moving,
but we've learned so much about the relation of these 2 things with this tilted Gaussian.
To understand how powerful this is, let's now fold in the second observation at time t = 2.
This observation tells us nothing about the velocity and only something about the location.
So if I were to draw this as a Gaussian--it's a Gaussian just like this,
which says something about the location but not about the velocity.
But if we multiply my prior from the prediction step with the measurement probability,
then miraculously, I get a Gaussian that sits right over here.
This Gaussian now has a really good estimate what my velocity is
and a really good estimate where I am.
If I take this Gaussian, and predict 1 step forward, then I find myself right over here.
That's exactly the effect we have over here.
After that I get a Gaussian like this, I predict right over here.
Think about this. This is a really deep insight about how Kalman filters work.
In particular, we've only been able to observe 1 variable.
We've been able to measure observation to infer this other variable,
and the way we've been able to infer is that there's a set of physical equations
which say that my location, after a times step, is my old location plus my velocity.
This set of equations has been able to propagate constraints from subsequent measurements
back to this unobservable variable, velocity, so we are able to estimate the velocity as well.
This is really key to understanding Kalman filter.
It is key to understanding how a Google self-driving car,
estimates the locations of other cars, and is able to make predictions
even if it's unable to measure velocity directly.
There's a big lesson here.
The variables of a Kalman filter--they're often called states because they reflect states
of the physical world like where the other car is and how fast it's moving.
They separate into 2 subsets--the observables, like the momentary location,
and the hidden, which in our example is the velocity, which I can never directly observe.
But because those 2 things interact, subsequent observations of the observable variables
give us information about these hidden variables, so we can also estimate
what these hidden variables are.
So from multiple observations of the places of the object--the location--
we can estimate how fast it's moving.
That is actually true for all of the different filters but because Kalman filters happen to be
very efficient to calculate, when we have a problem like this,
you tend to often use just a Kalman filter.